[Music]
birthday your to then to WRAS Atlanta
it's a very special birthday dedication
to one mr. John Green from all your
secret siblings and nerdfighters in
Atlanta this one goes out to you
[Music]
doing
it's just a jump to the left
[Music]
it's a dream or fantasy free me so you
can
not at all
[Music]
was why artists against
well secluded I see all with
you're into the times near and nothing
yes my startups in session today
[Music]
it's just a jump to the next
[Applause]
[Music]
happy birthday John have a jokes
birthday John Barker the Mark Twain
Museum hey John this is what the back
wishing you a very happy birthday happy
birthday mm a dog in John
hey John this is the Miss retirement
it's when I say happy birthday happy
birthday John had hip party bye John
that my friend is an anagram for happy
birthday John happy birthday John happy
birthday John hey John this is fall of
autumn distro just hoping you have a
very happy birthday in my pants happy
birthday John it's 11:55 and I haven't
rendered yet but the video is done it's
too long but that's okay because the
birthday videos are exemption but also I
could say that is a special gift from
the nerdfighters and I you're not going
to have to do your video tomorrow
because it's going to be a special
nerdfighter day and you will see what
that means and it means something pretty
awesome so I hope that you will enjoy
your day off and that you enjoyed the
video that you just watched and my hard
drive is officially full cramp so I got
to go bye